Apple's WWDC event is less than two
weeks away and we now have a very good
idea of what the event is going to be
focused on thanks to some new leaks and
rumors that just came out so let's get
right into it
the most important part of this event is
Apple finally announcing that they are
beginning the transition of their Macs
going from Intel chips over to their
very own ARM chips now if you don't
understand what that means it's
basically like taking an iPhone
processor and putting it into a macbook
and when they announce the transition to
arm they'll most likely show off some
new software for developers to start
rewriting and optimizing their apps to
get ready for actual ARM based Mac
hardware next year this is actually
exactly what Apple did way back when
they switched to Intel chips
check out the short clip we are going to
begin the transition from the PowerPC to
Intel processors and we are going to
begin it for you now and for our
customers next year so consumer max with
ARM chips probably won't get released
until 2021 but they could still easily
announce a new mac months in advance
like they did with the mac pro I
personally believe the very first arm
powered Mac will be an entry-level
MacBook possibly a new 2021 MacBook Air
this makes the most sense says this
laptop is meant for the average consumer
who needs to do basic computer things
unlike someone who needs to use
professional apps now for those who
watch my video titled stop don't buy an
iMac right now Congrats because we now
finally have some very convincing rumors
pointing to Apple releasing a brand new
iMac at WWDC the rumors mentioned
thinner display bezels like the pro
display XD are at2 coprocessor chip in
AMD navi GPU and iPad pro design
language and no more fusion drive the
reason the current IMAX don't have t2
chips is because they're using hard
drives or fusion drives so now that
they're going to be ditching them and
going SSD only we can finally get
two chips on IMAX now don't expect them
to go fully armed powered because the
rumors also point to an AMD navi GPU so
it needs to have a desktop x86 chip like
a new Intel comment Lake processor now
the iPad pro design language basically
means that it should look similar to the
pro display XDR with thinner vessels and
square edges on the sides this is
extremely exciting since it's been years
since Apple redesigned the iMac and
we're definitely getting one in ASAP so
if you're not already subscribed click
that button down below and in terms of
the release date john Prosser tweeted
recently that Apple has an iMac ready to
ship so based on that I personally
predict that this iMac will be open to
order starting at midnight on Friday the
26th of this month we should also expect
Apple to show off the future of the Mac
going forward with arm hardware because
remember Apple deeply cares about their
investors and showing off their arm base
roadmap will be huge for their stock
price so they can show off things like
Mac books finally getting fils ID which
will work right out of the box
thanks to the new ARM chips now this
actually makes a lot of sense if we take
a look at this WWDC invite image that
Apple created showcasing me emojis in
front of Mac books of course hinting at
face ID they could also show off how
much battery life we should expect to
see in these new arm Mac's and they'll
probably show off how well Final Cut Pro
10 logic pro 10 and Xcode run on these
new ARM chips and they may even announce
the new version of iPad OS which will be
able to run those apps just to prove
that it works they could also talk about
how the ARM chips will allow them to
make their Mac's thinner due to no
longer needing large cooling systems
since ARM chips don't get as hot and
they might even talk about how they'll
be able to take these arm chips and
scale them up to offer excellent
performance in the highest end machines
like the Mac Pro years down the line so
basically if Apple manages to pull this
off there's a chance that years late
the current x86 processors could end up
going extinct and ARM chips will become
the new norm for every computer so
enough about arm let's get right into
everything else we should expect to see
at WWDC obviously we should expect new
software for all of Apple's products
like iOS 14 iPad OS 14 watch OS 7 and
new Mac OS software but I think the main
features that we should watch out for
are sleep tracking for the Apple watch
and iPhone possibly Xcode Final Cut Pro
10 and Logic Pro 10 coming to the iPad
much more catalyst versions of iOS apps
coming to Mac OS 10 point 16 and kids
mode coming to the Apple TV of course
there's gonna be a lot more but those
are just a standout features that we
should expect to see now as far as the
hardware releases that we should expect
I'm confident that some of these that
I'm gonna mention will be announced at
WWDC but some of the others could wait
until summer or Apple's September event
on June 22nd we should expect Apple to
announce a new Apple TV 4k that will
come with an 8 12 X chip and probably a
new remote which may or may not be the
new gaming controller that we should
also expect which will be used for Apple
arcade gaming just as I mentioned before
we should see a new iMac getting
released at WWDC and it could possibly
come with support for that new gaming
controller since Mac OS already supports
Apple arcade a reliable leaker coin X
also mentioned that the Mac Mini will be
refreshed as well probably alongside the
iMac at WWDC but this will probably only
be a small spec update to include
Intel's new 10th gen chips Wi-Fi 6 and
support for Apple's 6k Pro display XDR
we should also expect to see a small
spec update to the 16 inch macbook pro
including new Intel attention processors
but there's a chance that Apple might
wait until some random time this summer
to release that MacBook there's a good
chance that Apple will announce the
first ARM based MacBook alongside the
announced
placement of the transition to ARM
processors but then again they may
decide to keep quiet on the arm hardware
until next year John Prosser also
mentioned that there is a new model of
air pods ready to ship right now but
there's also the totally separate air
pod Studio Headphones so there's a
chance that both of these will be
released at WWDC or there's also the
chance that Apple will wait until
September to release them but who knows
now there's also the Apple air tags
tracking devices and I'm really not sure
whether they're coming at the WWDC event
or the September event but definitely
one of those two and finally there's the
20/20 iPad air which is now rumored to
come with us PC and I personally believe
that it'll share the same exact frame or
body as the 11 inch iPad pro I
personally believe this will get
announced at WWDC since waiting until
September would only make sense for the
flagship iPad pro which was already
released in March so there you guys have
it that's what you should expect at this
year's WWDC and if you're interested in
why I think the new iPad air will share
the same frame as the 11 inch iPad pro
make sure to check out that video right
over there
and if you enjoyed this video click the
circle above to subscribe and make sure
to check out our brand new t-shirt
designs right below this video thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]